buongiorno ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
episodio di bichir correlati e ragazzi
nella puntata di oggi ora accolto come
sempre nei commenti le vostre i consigli
suggerimenti i suggerimenti di questa
puntata sono incredibili quindi partiamo
con video correlati number seven non lo
so la prima ricerca di oggi ragazzi va
da maurizio costanzo show a dragonball
partiamo
[Musica]
anche maurizio costanzo ok perfetto mi
mettiamo ammettiamo di essere certi
sorda
sì noi vero vero non ha retto in 34 anni
fa perfetta e fino a qua va bene
partiamo non so come farò a trovare
dragon ball però proviamoci
allora ragazzi la vedo molto difficile
però non solo arrivare a dragon ball in
realtà è cosa giorgio vanni di un pride
dove che a giorgio vanni quindi da
perché siamo sulla musica dai lander dj
che saluto voglio vedere se le scarpe
cari in qualche modo
cristina d'avena qui vediamo se esiste
cristina d'avena to play a suon console
va bene cercavo cristina d'avena un
cristiano davvero prova be fa niente
cristiano malgioglio al posto di
cristina d'avena e giorgia meloni
giorgio vanni però non so dove andare a
parare non ne ho idea qualcosa di
cartoonesco almeno to place male anche
perché non c'è non so come sono idea
ipantellas problemi parte la schiava
hanno fatto un video su dragon ball una
volta ma se gli anni 2000 tornassero
oggi fermo potrebbe avere un senso
questo questo aspetto c'è un drago di
copertina c'è un dragon ball in
copertina l'ho visto c'era andrea cocco
fraser
sei pronto i fantasmi salvano il chupete
grazie a como grazie tania jacopo ti
giuro io ti voglio un bene dell'anima ma
in questo video non è riguardato santhià
lo sto vedendo ciò record maurizio cosa
ci ho messo niente su un fenomeno o da
martin garics how are you
questo questo è difficile
[Musica]
facciamo martin gare c 130 si vuole già
bella ragazza
ok allora da quali marawori o non è
facile però vedo che perché e io non so
come michael bella ragazzi esco io come
cacchio e poi non è che dici vabbè
riguardato dei due mini ti consiglia
quelli no hanno guardato niente di fa di
jeremy esco io col bellaguarda guarda
guarda io comparti garri io col bella
ragazze con un c'è un motivo e tutto
questo comunque andiamo avanti e vediamo
se riusciamo in qualche modo limonata
con giulia penn a trovare in qualche
modo vario allora io l'ho fatto un video
su vario ma il proprio di tantissimo
tempo fa e comunque cercare un video tra
i miei è veramente difficile ragazzi
perché infatti un miliardo di video
quindi è proprio trovare un mio video in
mezzo e difficile me ne rendo conto però
possiamo provare perché non vedo altri
agganci quindi può vincere per forza
ridge ieri action parodi animata
troviamo un gioco c'era un gioco chiedo
troppo
vabbè dai 2 milioni schiti speciale che
con quel periodo in cui ho fatto uguale
era quello che vediamo a pescarlo
ragazzi per trovare wario se devo
provare a utilizzare una strategia io
andrei sulla nintendo qualcosa di
nintendo per questo star di suo vario e
l'unica cosa viene in mente ma la vedo
proprio difficilissima l'altro penso di
essere stato l'unico a portare guario
sul canale devo proprio beccare qualcosa
di nintendo fu difficilissimo ma
proviamo crimini che non c'entra niente
però meno qualcosa di nintendo vi dovrà
uscire non poi dai dio proprio wario
ragazzi vorrei veramente difficile porco
il demonio quali è impossibile
[Musica]
c'è veramente di giuro uguali o penso
sia la cosa più difficile tra tutti
quanti non so neanche non ho idea di
come arrivare a guarin date consiglio
facili che cacchio consigli senza avere
date le vede come più dei quiz per più
fattibili che cacchio lara brains magari
sui giochi tripla se continua a
consigliarvi giochi di platì può anche
il ponte di padre bellissimo quanto ero
sclerato in quel video mari o di sì
mario oggi si mariotti si fermi tutti i
mari o di si è uscito è uscito mario è
uscito mario vi amo ti amo ti amo mario
ti amo e lario costanzo show mario kart
coi makes su mario kart cielo resterà
wario queste ragioni varie qual è il
problema che io intelligente ma anche un
po testa di cazzo non l'ho messo nel
titolo quindi non sito mettiamo nel
titolo seconda cosa questo teoricamente
non va bene perché non ce n'è il titolo
capito cioè io avrei dovrebbe esserci
nel titolo perché il fatto che non ci
sia nel titolo non mi permette di
vincere la partita perché deve proprio
esserci nel titolo porca vacca
maledizione quindi io ho trovato il
video di wario ma non ho azzeccato la
parte
facciamo che questo e vale come appunto
a metà
ok perché vuole è difficilissimo mi sono
fatto un culo così ho trovato questo
vero non c'è nel titolo però sto
questo di questo è bello da gente killer
mitico gf kill a internet
[Musica]
non c'entrano la sega però proviamoci
c'è d'acqua all'interno posso mai
arrivare a niente di tutto ciò
l'impossibile jack the killer goes on
micro facciamone un video di gfk
comunque così ecco certe killer e mio
fratello fa vigente no non prendiamo
famigie andiamo subito a caso di jeff
miller
mi sono già partito un timpano ciao
ok allora virus succede kg ce l'abbiamo
ma anche arrivare all'interno come
arriviamo all'inter devo arrivare al
cane della serie a sempre quello premier
come cacchio ci arrivò con qualcosa di
calcio raga perché in realtà il calcio
non è introvabile
i fan della se proviamo a pensare alla
carta pantella sun questa volta che
abbiamo fatto una crossbar magari esce
visto che mi consiglia famiglia nemico
si è fan della unione la nostra crossbar
challenge potrebbe avere un senso se me
la consiglia se no ma niente foodwatch
alle gb chiedetevi se mi sento qualcuno
mette bis
perfetto allora mette bizet perché ami
così canale della serie a dai porti a
casa parla di gaggio la juventus mia pur
gatti ma che è ma cosa me ne frega mia
avanti l'inter con la meta di intercetto
tutte le squadre adesso inter milan e
sul calcio che mi fate vincere video con
relativi a mo di limone rai tutte e due
[Musica]
ne manca uno e facciamo l'ultimo come
riscaldamento finale ne ho veramente un
sacco di altri che nel prossimo episodio
non avete idea di che cacchio vederlo
fuori da pomeriggio 5 a rocket league
[Musica]
allora come la barbarona nazionale
pomeriggio cinque non è la d'urso
ok andiamo avanti rocket league fa dj vj
c'è sempre quindi consociativi convinto
di roche click e sarebbe incredibile
ragazzi ci pensate se gli spuntano che
ti no province e smontati fatemi
spuntano il video di rocket vi prego
allora fa vj perfetto rocket abbiamo
fatto un miliardo di video dove parlo
dei gatti miei quindi spero iddio di di
beccare un video di rocket league perché
akino fatti un miliardo ultimamente
eccolo eravamo io do massiccio eravamo
io e basta sono un fenomeno quattro a
tre scopi del leggendario leggendario
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
vi mando un bacio vi voglio bene e ci
vediamo a questo video di video
correlati manda scrivete mi raccomando
qua sotto nei commenti suggerimenti di
che cosa andare a cercare nel prossimo
episodio molto importante ragazzi perché
io seguivo scelto veramente solo le
vostre cose che mi scrivete questo che
ho detto oggi erano commenti vostri
iscrivetevi schiaccia dalla campanellina
primavera giudici 2000 che escono eroi
come sempre ci riuniamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]